Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This will be my Shazam. Fury of the Gods.
Full breakdown
and Easter eggs for the entire movie.
There were a bunch of references.
So if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
carefully for spoilers for the movie
if you haven't seen it yet.
When? Just start at the beginning. Work
our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs, WTF moments
and obviously the post credits scenes.
The title Fury of the Gods is a reference
to the gods they got their powers from.
They explained the origin
of Shazam's powers as a couple changes
from the comics with the whole backstory.
But essentially
the movie was designed to be in the DCU.
Like when they were filming it,
it was still the DCU.
James Gunn wasn't hired and didn't
do the big DC Studios reboot or didn't
plan to do it until way
later in the post-production process.
So there were a couple of minor changes
in a couple of characters
that they did not wind up, including
that they'd originally planned on doing.
Like originally
they were going to be more Justice League
characters like Superman, Batman,
in addition to Wonder Woman.
In originally,
they tried to get the rock to cameo
as Black Adam to have a Shazam versus
Black Adam type of scene during the movie,
but he declined to do that.
That was before his big dustup
with the studio and James Gunn was hired,
and then he had a big falling out
with Warner Brothers
and basically has left DC
like he will not come back as black.
Adam It's a
because
there's
six of us and there's seven thrones.
Who's who's that for?
Well, whoever it is,
I'm going to love them no matter what
because they're an automatic part
of the family in general.
The movie's
meant to pick up about two years
after the end of the last movie
where Billy is about to turn 18
and become an adult
according to the law of the United States.
The way they explained
the powers of Shazam in the movie
is that a long time ago
the Wizard created the staff of Atlas
for the Greek Titan Atlas,
who was the most powerful God at the time,
more powerful than Zeus and is made
to flow with real world Greek mythology
where the titans came before the younger
gods, Zeus defeated the Titans.
It sounds like what happened is Zus helped
the Wizard Shazam and some of the other
gods helped the Wizard take down Atlas
and take his staff and his powers.
But the idea is that
he forged the staff of Atlas from the Wood
from the Tree of Life
and gave that to Atlas as a gift.
And Atlas used that to either take
or bestow different
God powers on different lesser gods.
A lot of you asking,
Does this change the back story
from the Wonder Woman movie
about what happened to the Greek gods?
Because during that they have a prolog
where they explain that Aries rebelled
against the other gods like zoos killed
most of them in zoo, sacrificed himself
to stop Arya's temporarily while
also creating the enchantment on them.
A Kira preventing anyone from finding it.
Even Wonder Woman.
So the funny thing is they haven't
really gotten into this in the movies yet.
But Zack Snyder was going to deal with it
during the Justice League sequels
when he was still doing it.
Justice League
trilogy is the magic that Zeus put on
Themyscira is so powerful
that even Wonder Woman can't
find her way back to them in Sekiro
unless someone inside them, a squirrel,
tells her how to get there,
like fire as an arrow out of themyscira.
But at some point, Zeus and the other gods
help the wizard Shazam take down Atlas.
He took his staff,
drained all of his power from it,
and then created a magical barrier
that prevented anyone from the God
realm entering the regular dimension.
And the way they explain this,
they go by the Grant Morrison
more diversity
explanation behind the multiverse,
where the God realm is just
another dimension within the multiverse.
The whole idea is that
during the first Shazam movie,
they explained that
when Billy broke the staff
that brought down the enchantment,
protecting the main dimension from the God
realm, allowing the sisters back in.
So it wasn't clear the wizard
didn't kill all other gods.
Some of them were killed
by other gods like Aries,
or they use it the rest of their power and
wound up growing old and dying that way.
The whole idea
is that up to the end of the movie,
when they bring magic
back to the God realm.
Up to that point,
there had been no more magic.
There are very little magic,
so most of the gods had died off.
That's why
they say at the end of the movie
that there is no more spark of divinity
out there.
And Wonder Woman shows up
and it's like, Yeah,
I have a slight spark of a God left in me
because my father was Zeus.
This also meant to explain
where she gets her power from
because she has part of this power.
But they change the opening titles
and now they're meant to be a reference
to the rock that forms the Gods
castle of the God realm.
All the powers that His spirit has,
turning all the humans into rock.
Also just the ancient nature
of a lot of the Greek artifacts
that you see, a reference
to the ancient nature of the Greek gods.
But the actual opening scene
takes place at the Greek Acropolis nearby
the History Museum.
You see where his spirit Calypso,
come to take the staff of Atlas,
their father, played by Helen Mirren
and Lucy Liu.
They explain the reason
why the staff wound up there,
because after the events
of the first movie,
when Billy broke the staff,
he just threw it in the trash
and it wound up in the Philly garbage dump
where it broke three trash compactors.
Once the authorities found it, they
discovered that it was a Greek artifact.
So the nation of Greece cleaned it
and they sent it into a Greek museum.
That's why at the end of the movie,
they had the joke where the wizard
comes back saying that he's
going to go on a tour of the world
just enjoying himself
because he's in prison for so long.
But he's going to keep the staff with him
for safekeeping
because he's pretty sure that Billy
would probably do
something stupid with it again.
The three daughters of the Titan
Atlas were a thing in real world
Greek mythology,
but the backstory
was a little bit different.
They were called the disparities.
Their powers were a little bit different,
and there was a garden of golden apples
in a tree of life.
But it was the garden of the disparities.
Like the garden belonged to the three
sisters, where the tree in the apples
grew.
The actual tree itself
had been a gift from Zeus to Hera,
the dragon Laden was also from real world
Greek mythology,
and it did exactly what they said
in the movie.
It guarded the garden.
The actual garden
and the golden apples were featured
during the ten Labors of Hercules, too.
One of his challenges was to steal
one of the golden apples from the garden.
When you enter the museum,
there's a giant statue of Atlas,
which spear repurposes with her magic
to turn everyone into stone,
which is meant to be a twist
on the whole idea
that all these ancient Greek artifacts
were on display.
And now the humans are on display.
The sisters are dressed like hoplites.
That's
what wealthier Greek soldiers were called
because they wore armor
that they provided themselves.
So only the wealthier people in Greece
could become hoplites.
Armor like that during
that era was very expensive.
You probably recognize the tour guide
Rizwan Manji, who was just in peacemaker.
Season one, is a character named Jameel
that isn't meant to be the same person.
So I guess you could say
it's a long lost twin. Maybe.
The scissors in general
are meant to be between 6010
thousand years old,
maybe a little bit older than that.
But it goes back to a little
before that Dark Side War flashback,
which was about 10,000 years ago.
By that time, the wizard had already
defeated the Greek Titan Atlas.
You also remember that
Black Adam is from about 5000 years ago.
Wonder Woman is also about 5000 years.
When Black Adam was getting his powers
in conduct, Wonder Woman was being born.
That makes Anthea about a thousand years
older than Wonder Woman.
They have a couple of jokes
about that during the movie.
Like, you look super good for being so old
after they kill everyone in the museum,
They said at the Shazam reveal
with the joke about the wizard
choosing the smartest,
most cunning, powerful champion possible.
We have to watch out.
Cutting to Billie in Child Therapy
with PJ Byrne, who plays his therapist.
You might recognize him
from a bunch of other things.
He's also on the boys TV show. Right now.
Emily feels like a fraud, making a whole
bunch of Justice League references.
Like he talks about Superman, Batman,
Wonder Woman, the Flash and Cyborg,
like The Flash's, the other guy
with the red costume,
with the lightning bolts on it.
And he's way better than he is
if you look around the doctor's office
here, too,
there's a ton of DC Easter eggs.
Probably the biggest WTF is the Green
Lantern Easter egg in the background.
But like there are a bunch of Wonder Woman
plushies.
There's an S for Starro
in the background here
referencing the events
of the Suicide Squad movie.
There's Titane.
Oh the super ape from the Superman comics
that represents the letter T.
He was a chimp named Toto
that was sent to space during a test
flight and was bombarded with cosmic rays
that gave him superpowers
that Superman fought way,
way back in the classic comics,
there's several Wonder
Woman plushies, there's Batman plushies,
there's a Batman action figure,
there's a flash action figure.
But like I said,
there's a Green Lantern action figure,
meaning the Green Lantern
already exists in this continuity
and this is meant
to take place in the DCU.
Like this is the new timeline,
like the movie
takes place around the same time
as the events of the Black Adam movie,
so that the Shazam doesn't
get caught up in
what's happening
during the Black Adam movie.
They explain why
they don't rush over to conduct.
You also notice there's an Easter egg
for the Annabel doll from the director's
horror movie.
The Annabel movie is like
he comes from an indie horror background.
That's how he came to the Shazam
franchise.
You notice
when he's flying through the city
talking about how he's been a lousy
superhero the past couple of years.
There's a few different footage of Freddie
Freeman complaining about being hurt
by something, and he's wearing another
big Easter Egg reference t shirt.
It's a Batman and Robin t shirt,
but this time it's an actual bat
dressed as Batman in an actual Robin
Bird dressed as Robin.
They also use this scene
to recap the events of the first movie.
Just to remind you
about Billy's back story,
The joke about the hostage situation
he has to go to is a video game that he's
playing with the others,
which is supposed to be practice
for them, working
as a team, saving people.
They feel the game,
which is a parallel for them in real life,
being hated by the city
who call them the Philadelphia fiascos.
They set up Dalia's Skittles joke.
Later in the movie Taste the Rainbow.
With the Skittles,
she surprises Mary Marvel
with leaving them in her pocket
so they wind up staining her pants.
You notice she's playing with a model
unicorn in a mock battle diorama
with an army of unicorns
just setting up her army of unicorns.
Later in the movie,
Billy is wearing a Goonies t shirt
because that's the whole vibe of the movie
in general.
And their group Goonies never say die
Bunch of kids going on adventures
together.
Freddie Freeman is wearing a tree t shirt,
which I think
is meant to be the white tree of Gondor
from the Lord of the Rings movies.
But it's also meant to be a reference to
the Tree of Life at the end of the movie.
Also, the lightning ring
that he's wearing is a reference
to all the Elvis Easter Eggs and Captain
Marvel Jr In the Golden Age comics,
Freddie Freeman's name was Captain Marvel.
JR In the movie, he calls himself
Captain Every Powers, which is a reference
to Captain Marvel, the original name
of the Shazam character in the comics.
But they had a big legal problem
with Marvel, even though technically
I think DC owned the rights to the Captain
Marvel name before Marvel did.
But in the movie that's why he calls Billy
Captain Every Powers JR
Because that was Freddie
Freeman's original name in the comics
and bringing it back around to Elvis.
Elvis grew up in real life.
Being a fan of the Captain
Marvel Junior Comics in model, his whole
look after him, hair and everything,
some of his crazier costumes too.
That's also why his TCB pendant taking
care of business
has the lightning bolt on,
and he wears a ring just like that too,
which is a reference to Freddie
Freeman's lightning ring.
Pretty cool finding out
that Elvis used to be a comic book nerd.
They said at the Big Pedro Twist,
where he reveals the family that he's gay,
even though everyone else
in the family claims
that they've known the whole time,
or for at least a long time.
They're also watching the Phillies game on
TV, which is happening at the stadium,
foreshadowing the end of the movie
with the battle at Phillies Stadium
when they first activate their powers
together.
The graffiti on the fence
to the right, Torba And Drew Nadel
is actually a reference to the two schools
where director David Sandberg went
and he met his wife later,
who also has a cameo in the movie.
She's
the nurse that Billy saves on the bridge.
She also played Doctor Savannah's
assistant in the first Jasmine movie, who
he wound up killing.
David Sandberg actually plays
two different characters in this movie.
He has a cameo seen as a random citizen
who gets killed by the monsters
and carried off.
He's also the voice of Mister
Mind in the Post Credits scene.
The other thing you notice here
is that the Mary Marvel actress is now
playing both versions of the character,
the regular in the powered up version.
They said they did that
just because the actress
had gotten old enough and it made sense.
They also updated all their costumes
and reshot the power scene
from the first movie.
When they're talking about what Billy did,
breaking the staff like,
they completely reshot that scene
with these actors in these costumes.
So it's a slight retcon,
but you can actually chalk it up
to being Billy, remembering events
and just remembering them
slightly differently.
They also make it sound like their foster
father, Victor had started to figure out
that the kids were the superheroes
early in the movie, but Rosa didn't learn
until they barge in on them
at the end of the movie.
Like,
have you ever noticed that the superheroes
always show up
the minute that the kids take off?
Back at the rugby tourney,
you see Freddy hang up a newspaper
clipping of all their superhero saves.
One of them reads Lightning
Man in Wonder Woman Romance, sending out
the whole Wonder Woman Billy obsession
during the movie and her cameo scene.
Like I said,
the director also said at one point
they were going to have cameos
from the entire Justice League
like Superman, Batman.
But it just caused too many logic problems
and practical problems
behind the scenes.
When the big James Gunn
reboot announcement happened.
So they just decided not to include them.
But what they would have done is
they would have shown up
when the dome goes over the city
and tried to pound their way in like
Superman would not have been able
to make his way through the barrier.
He also said the dome around the city
was inspired by the Simpsons movie.
You see a wide shot
tour of the Rock of Eternity lair.
They turned it into the little kids
idea of a bat cave with a bunch of video
games, toys, all kinds of memorabilia
from the Justice League,
like a lot of real world DC memorabilia.
But it's in Universe.
Like there's a bunch of merch in the DCU
that's being created
because of the Justice
League characters in there buying it.
They do the same thing
in the Marvel movies,
like there are Captain America
Comics inside the Marvel Universe.
So their references to Batman logos,
all kinds of stuff
all over the Rock of Eternity,
they even had a Batman mug.
And it's Michael Keaton.
Batman's logo on the mug.
So let that twist your brain up.
What universe is this happening in?
You can blame that on the flash.
The flash point twist in the Flash movie
with all the timelines getting crazy.
They said at the Mary College storyline
with her reading the organic chemistry
book is all about her
trying to get into college
because she deferred her enrollment
after the first movie
because she's already
supposed to be in college right now.
Later in the movie,
you see her wearing the Oxford sweater
and in the credits
flying off with her powers,
just saying that
she eventually went to Oxford.
But she's going to continue
to work with the family, they explain.
Eugene has been mapping the room of doors,
which are meant to be doors
to different dimensions,
and they just have funny markings
on all of them.
Like I said, it's
based on the Grant Morrison multiverse.
The version of the multiverse.
I'm not sure who the spider dog is
meant to be a reference to.
There's not a spider dog in DC Comics,
so this is just meant to be Eugene
referring to something
that looks kind of like a spider
in a dog, crossed
one of the doors, leads to the fairy land,
which is probably a reference to the magic
lands of the seven realms of magic,
which are the seven different dimensions
that are all made of pure magic.
The place that Mr.
Mind is trying to take control of that
he references in the Post Credits scene.
So the first and the second movie doing
that would basically give him control over
all magic in the entire multiverse,
all of reality,
making him pretty much invincible
when he gets bit out the door
by the monster
all covered in goo and says,
Do not go in there.
That's meant to be an Ace
Ventura reference.
Do not go in there when Darla brings
the kitten back and names it Tawny.
That's meant to be a reference
to Tony the Tiger from the Shazam comics.
You also know this in the background
of this scene, there's a stuffed tiger.
Also another Tony the Tiger reference.
Billy starts making more wonder
Woman jokes, talking about her
having a secret identity,
working a day job.
That's a reference to her
Diana Prince persona in her actual job.
Like her real job
she has at the Louvre in Paris.
Also,
the joke about her wearing a ponytail
and glasses
and no one recognizing her is a reference
to the original Wonder
Woman TV show, the Diana Prince persona
in a bit of a Superman
Clark Kent reference to, like what?
She's going to put glasses on
and no one's going to recognize her.
That'd be ridiculous.
Then we find out
the three sisters have held
the Wizard Shazam captive
since the end of the last movie.
The way he explains that he's still here
is that his essence died
basically in traveled in.
The sisters caught it
in, captured it and put it in prison here.
So he did actually die
during the first movie.
But him coming
back is meant to foreshadow Billy
also being able to come back from death.
Freddy winds up meeting Anthea,
who's pulling a never been kissed at
their school, pretending to be a student
when really she's a super old person.
Freddie is also wearing an iron
giant t shirt.
It's an amazing movie. If you haven't seen
it, you should definitely check it out.
But in that the robot pretends that it is
Superman, like it calls itself Superman.
Now the Iron Giant, in addition
to the Fast and Furious movies
or CONAN to the DC Universe,
when they mention Thunder, Crack,
Make a Wish, That's a reference to Billy.
That's
what they call Billy in this universe.
And it's a reference to the Superman scene
at the end of the first movie
where Shazam and Superman have lunch
with Freddie while he's in regular form.
Diedrich Bader plays his principal
who winds up being killed
by the three sisters. So R.I.P..
But Diedrich Bader has also been
in a bunch of DC TV shows as the voice
of Batman, most notably in Batman
Brave in the Bold and in present day.
Big coincidence James Gunn's Connected
DCU Batman movie is going to be called
Batman Brave in the Bold.
Tell me something
and I need the absolute truth.
Do I look fat in this outfit?
There, that funny Billy dream sequence
where he fantasizes about going on a date
with Wonder Woman playing
it mostly as a joke with the wizard
phase winding up on her body
because the wizard is speaking to him
in his dreams when he wakes
up, the plasma ball blowing up on his desk
is meant to give him the idea
to do the exact same thing in the dome
at the end of the movie.
Destroying the Tree of Life, Calypso
and the dragon zooming enhance
in the background of their bedroom.
You see another Annabelle poster for the
director David Sandberg's Annabel movies.
You also notice during this scene too,
all over their bedroom,
there are pictures of all the Justice
League characters
The Flash, Batman, Superman,
Wonder Woman, of course, Aquaman, Cyborg,
the Iconoclast Poster
is for a video game,
the same one Eugene is wearing earlier
in the movie.
Behind them on the wall, you see their
high school is named Fawcett High School.
It's a reference to Fawcett Comics,
which was the original comic book
publisher of Whiz Comics, where Shazam,
the Captain Marvel character got started.
Eventually, DC bought Fawcett
and that's how the Shazam characters
became part of the DC Universe.
They set the burning violin for later
in the movie to use as a twist
for an in-universe joke
that they still don't understand
what it is or how it works,
only that it's weird and it's distracting.
The sisters,
but it's actually from the comics.
It's a reference to two different things
one in the comics and one in real world
history during Captain Marvel Adventures,
Volume one, Number 64.
When he was fighting Ogre in Nero,
he plays a fiddle spewing fire,
trying to burn down New York.
In real world history, the mad Caesar
Nero is said to have fiddled
during the great Fire of Rome in 64 A.D.
Pedro winds up showing them
the library in the Rock of Eternity,
which contains the sum total
of all magical and mystical knowledge
mythology, lore,
pretty much everything relating to magic.
They also set up the joke with them,
learning about the Shazam acronym
in the source of their powers.
Like, Oh, it all stands for an acronym.
The Wisdom of Solomon,
The Strength of Hercules, the Stamina
of Atlas, The Power of Zeus, The Courage
of Achilles in the Speed of Mercury.
The joke about the wisdom of Solomon is
that it's not about him.
Literally being super smart.
It's more about the wisdom in his heart.
Like emotional smarts.
In the comics, it was more of a
traditional intelligence kind of power.
Originally gave him
clairvoyance, awareness and battle.
It also gave him knowledge
of all languages,
ancient and modern warfare,
and allowed him to hypnotize people.
The other joke
here, too, is that Billy says
The wizard didn't leave me a manual
about how all these powers worked.
He has no idea how to use his powers,
which they pay off later
with the Book of Shazam,
which is literally an entire history
about how his powers work like, Oh,
you probably would have figured this out
if you just read the book in the library.
One of the funny things about Shazam two
is that he actually can cast
spells like a normal magician.
We cast spells.
It is because he's a little kid.
He has no idea how to do that yet.
Is there like a Scarlet Witch situation
in the Marvel Universe
where she has this crazy power level
and can seemingly do all kinds of magic
without having to do
the normal things that regular wizards,
magicians, sorcerers do?
Shazam is just like that
in the DC Universe.
He just hasn't figured out
exactly how to tap into that ability yet.
The books blabbing around
being semi sentient
also felt kind of like a Harry Potter
reference in as far as I know, Steve,
the pen is not from the comics.
They just use this to set up Billy's
magical letter to Wonder Woman
at the end of the movie,
letting her know to come check in on them
so she can save his life.
The joke they play with the pen, though,
is that the pen knows everything
that is contained in the library,
but it's only as good
like you can only give them answers
that are as good as the questions
that they ask.
It'd be like typing in really terrible
searches and questions into Google search.
Like it would just give you terrible
answers because your questions are bad.
Should we proofread it?
Nah, Steve doesn't make mistakes.
Just writes what you say. Great.
I feel good about this. Me too.
Anyone else want a to read?
Do we have read?
So when the pen starts explaining things,
it could have actually told them way
more information,
way more specific information
if they had known to ask it
specific questions like Pen, how do you
kill Superman?
The pen could tell you how to kill
Superman.
The scissors come for Freddie,
Throw him in prison with the wizard.
When he meets them,
he makes another Batman reference,
claiming the wizard has a Batman voice
inside the sister's throne room.
There's a statue of their father, Atlas,
holding the world on his back
just like in Greek mythology.
Like earlier in the movie, in the museum,
the fake names
that Freddie gives the sisters
when they ask him to name the champions
Brett Brier, Brooke Brier are people
that were mean to him at his school,
hoping that they'll go after them
for just a hot second
until they figure out that it was a ruse.
Oh, yeah.
One of the champions,
he drives this Dodge pickup truck.
The person that was mean to him
during the first movie,
when they get thrown to the dragon
in the pit, the real power of the dragon
is that it brings out your worst fears
and turns them up to 11, making people
who try to enter the disparities garden
so terrified that you turn around
and run away.
But in addition to that, it is a giant,
super strong dragon that can also eat you.
The Colonel cheesesteak joke
is probably a reference to a restaurant
called Colonel Mustards in Philly,
which is serves famous sandwiches.
They make the Fast and Furious joke,
which was in all the trailers.
Helen Mirren, Djimon Hounsou, Gal Gadot,
Wonder Woman were also in the Fast
and Furious movies.
And now those movies are also canon
to the DC Universe.
It's kind of like Samuel L Jackson playing
both Nick Fury and Mace Windu
in the Star Wars movies, in the Star Wars
movies being canon to the MCU.
So Spider-Man notices Nick Fury saying,
Wait a minute, you look kind of like
that guy in the Star Wars movies
when they take a spear, a prisoner.
Dahl also reveals that she thinks yellow
Skittles are like the word Skittles.
They reveal their secret to the parents
and the Dragon attacks,
which they also joke about later
when Victor asks, Is that the reason why
lightning kept striking the house?
Because you're all Shazam.
Which they also pay off
at the end of the movie when he hangs up
the sign well, the remodeling, the house
saying no, Shazam inside the house
when calypso plants the golden apple
and the tree of life starts growing,
the monsters start coming out of it.
We get our director David Sandberg
cameos in is his carried away and killed
his spear makes a reference
to Hades saying that he's their uncle.
Hades is the Greek god
who rules the underworld brother to zoos.
He'd also be Wonder Woman's uncle too.
The reason why the sisters fight
with themselves about what to do with
the apple is because the Spirit and Thea
want to restore magic in their realm.
It will restore all the power of the God
realm.
Calypso wants to use it
to destroy the Earth.
When they start fighting Shazam makes
the Game of Thrones Khaleesi reference
because Calypso is riding a dragon
just like DeNiro's Targaryen was in.
When he rallies,
he gets a pep talk from Michael Gray,
who was Billy Batson on the Shazam
TV show in the 1970s.
He's one of the big celebrity
cameos of the movie Shazam.
He's also wearing a red and yellow t shirt
like Billy Batson, Shazam colors.
They pay off the Skittles reference
for the taste the Rainbow unicorn joke.
The director actually said
that they actually put
a bunch of those jokes in,
then they had to go to skills
and get permission.
Like, Wait a minute, there are way
too many Skittles references in this.
We only get permission in after the fact.
They even did a special Skittles trailer.
Shazam winds up sacrificing himself
to destroy the tree
and the dragon paying off the plasma
ball scene earlier in the movie.
And when they bury him
the next day in the God realm,
Wonder Woman arrives, getting his message,
the God message to reignite
the God spark in the staff of Atlas,
which the Wizard uses to restore magic
in the entire God realm, causing Billy
to also come back to life with his powers.
Bringing the tree itself back to life
also gives Anthea her powers back too.
They claim before this, though,
that no gods were left,
even though Anthea is still alive.
I think what they meant at the time is
they thought there were no more people
with God powers because Anthea lost hers
early in the movie.
So like I said, this means that Wonder
Woman still has a spark of divinity in her
a small portion of Zuma's power
because she is his biological daughter.
They pay off all the jokes
about Billy's obsession with Wonder Woman,
trying to ask her out on a date
and her just telling him, okay, kid,
just worry about saving the world
and tells them to use her father's
powers, use his power wisely.
He also tries to joke about the fact
that they're not related
just because part of her father
is also in him.
And also he's turning 18 very soon.
So he will technically be an adult.
She wouldn't be going out with a minor
at the dinner scene.
Anthea says
she's going to spend time on Earth.
She'll be going out with Freddie
like there are a couple now,
but she's just going to spend time
amongst mortals
getting to know what culture is like. Now.
The wizard Shazam also comes back and says
that he's going to tour around the world
and have fun because he was locked up
in prison for so long.
Also to take the staff back
into safekeeping because he knows
the bill is going to do something
stupid with it.
You notice that Freddie Freeman
is also wearing a Gremlins two shirt.
I think this is a reference
to the second Gremlins movie.
And Darla is wearing a unicorn shirt
for the unicorn.
She just got done
winning over with the Skittles.
If the characters come back,
I'm sure they'll find a way to pay off
that Taste the Rainbow joke again.
They make another joke
about what his name should actually be,
and the wizard tells him
Your name is Shazam, which I think
is another callback to the idea
that his name used to be Captain Marvel,
but now it's Shazam.
And during the actual end credits,
they have the Elvis music,
a little less conversation,
which, like I said, is a callback
to the Captain Marvel Jr persona
that Elvis used to inform
his whole character confirmed.
Now Elvis was a super comic book nerd.
All the different credits scene.
Still, the drawings are meant to depict
the events of the movie
and the different characters and
what winds up happening to the characters.
You also see a page depicting Billy
with all the different gods
that are the source of his powers
and the PlayStation controller symbols,
which is another joke about him.
Misusing the powers like a kid would just
be really awesome at video games.
Then we get the post credits scenes.
There are two of them.
I've already done
a much longer video about it,
but basically the first Post Credits
scene is Amelia Harcourt
and John economist from Peacemaker Season
one from the Suicide Squad movie
Recruiting Shazam to the Justice Society,
the one that we saw during the Black Adam
movie for Amanda Waller,
originally the director, David
Sandberg said that they were going to have
the actual Justice Society characters
show up during this scene to recruit him
like Hawkman
and the others would have shown up
and said, Hey, Billy, come join the team.
And it was still played it
for the same joke.
Like when they show up
and ask him to join the justice,
they don't get the sentence
the full way out
because he says a thousand times, yes,
because he wants to be on the team
with Wonder Woman
so bad on the Justice League,
but they finish the sentence society
and he gets all pissed off
making a bunch of jokes
about their naming conventions.
Like, why would you need two of your teams
the same thing?
Justice if they're not related at all,
Giving them a couple of suggestions
for other potential names.
One of them is the Authority Society,
which is a reference
to the authority movie
that James Gunn is getting ready to do.
There are a Wildstorm team
also saying the Avengers Society,
which is a big Marvel reference
because James Gunn also just came
to become the new Kevin Foggy of DC
after doing all the Marvel movies.
Guardians of the Galaxy three recently.
The second Post Credit
scene is almost the exact same
post credit scene as the second one
from the first movie with Dr.
Sivana in Mr.
Mind talking about the same thing
they talked about during the first movie.
He shows up
and they joke about how long it's been.
It's been two years.
Why is it taking so long,
This evil plan that you're developing
to take over the magic lands in Mr.
Mind yells at him to be patient.
It takes a long time and references
growing wings getting really big,
which is another comic book
reference to his final boss form.
There's a couple other Easter eggs
during this Post Credit
scene that I get into much more detail
in during my Post Credit scenes video,
so I'll link that at the end of this.
But if there any other Easter eggs
in the other parts of the movie
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Like I said, the characters
coming back in future DC movies
just depends on how the movie does
financially.
Right now I'm expecting them to recast,
but they did leave the door open.
The way they explained things.
Everyone click here for those Shazam
Fury of the Gods Post Credits scenes
and click here for my new Justice League
Dark Side trailer Video from Zack Snyder.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.